now I want you to write these with me
actually not you don't need the whole
thing you just have a look at these guys
okay let's notice a few things do you
notice the powers that I've got how is
that I've got they're all odd do you
notice that now you can you can include
even ones as well but it shouldn't
surprise are some of the intuition
should sort of support why we want odd
powers for sine X Y would on powers fit
with sine X and not so much the even
ones because sine x is like
quintessential odd function right and
therefore if you want to retain that
kind of symmetry like for example see
this per hour from here right you have
to lean all the way over this side to
get it right but these guys also sent up
on there they after they have the same
kind of symmetry built into them okay
now it takes a bit of hefty calculus to
get on all these numbers down here okay
but I want you to write down let's write
down this one will do this one will do
it it's a part that you can't see just
consider well the one that I've got
highlighted for instance this is how
much of it this is how much of it I had
to do to get the level accuracy to fool
you that it would look just like sine X
okay so you don't need to write all of
that but if you just write you know this
pattern here this is a function I've got
X take away X cubed on three factorial
plus X to the five five factorial the
science alternate that's suspicious
okay you get the idea wait I've got
another board now so you can use that
instead of the screen okay
now because what we want is like a
proper approximation of the sine
function I'm gonna need this need to go
forever like what does that to go
forever because the sine goes forever
and it has an infinite number of roots
and if a number's stationary points so
if I stop anywhere I'm stuck if I stop
at a million although let me have only
have a million stationary points right
well this was that infinite and there's
an infinite chasm between infinity and a
million okay so this really does have to
go forever so what is a way to be able
to write forever that's right infinity
without having to write an infinite
number of terms only I had a way of
writing and inferred a series of things
that all look very similar to each other
change a little bit I could use Sigma
notation now it's not that's the problem
right well the living sum is sine X okay
so that's it right it's not right now
think with me what will I do
how will I like this in Sigma notation
oh they get one okay now what you'll
notice is now I'm not gonna because of
you know time and your brain is rapidly
exploding okay I'll show you what my
answer is
but I want you to know it I am gonna
have to use this um I'm gonna be
switching back to thing right because
look there science keep on alternating
I'm also using only the odd powers right
so when we were going to like general
solution everything how did I what did I
use to just get odd numbers 2 and plus 1
or 2 and minus 1
they both the same okay so here's what
I've got I think I've gone from N equals
0 to infinity the standard form of
writing this looks like this you got to
switch out the front you've got to +1 do
you see for N equals 0 that gives us
this guy yeah and then you can tell me
what's on the denominator if it's the
power whatever that power was with a
factorial oh yeah so this is 2 n plus 1
factorial so like I said it takes some
pretty hefty calculus to rigorously
prove this thing but we can still
appreciate how it's working what it's
doing ok now this guy has a special name
okay I'm this whole process this whole
process of trying to take some real
function and so approximate it with a
polynomial this is called polynomial
thank you
this is called polynomial interpolation
that's just a fancy word that means just
get me close can you get me close
polynomial interpolation and this result
that you get out this very special
infinite sum
it's a series right the guy who first
devised these things he was called
Taylor so this is called a Taylor slows
okay Taylor series it's a very very
important structure then I'm those of
you who do any kind of maths at
university will be dealing with of what
just the point is I can come up with an
infinite sum and I can I can approximate
I think interplay any function you
anything that's quite an amazing fit all
right now there's another sign by the
way this is science and because I'm
something to infinity it's not
approximately equals to it is actually
equal to which is a crazy idea
okay now continue to play this game with
me remember we're actually in complex
numbers right I've just dealt with sign
what do you think it would look like
because just think about it for a second
right what kind of symmetry does cause
matter even it has even symmetry so it
shouldn't surprise you that you're going
to use not the odd powers but all of the
even powers right so I again just for
the sake of time I've got already
written out what the our Taylor series
for the cosine function is it's one take
away or you got it the format is one
with identical you have the same
switching you have the same factorials
and so it would okay
and this is the Taylor series for cosine
again we can write it in in super
notation what have I got here
here I'm still gonna have to switch
around like this maybe it can help me a
little bit if I've already got this bit
I need some cows of X what powers of X
do I need
yeah it's just two and that will give me
all the even numbers right and then on
the bottom here it's just two N 1
factorial don't forget it even works for
this file no I've written it differently
but that's X to the naught on not
factorial right
I'm not isn't even number by the way I
know it seems a bit weird but it follows
all the properties that even numbers do
so there you go yeah right now do you
remember
I went from reticle X plus iy and I said
well let's get it written ones let's get
rid of those guys ok
and so I replaced them with these I'm
gonna pull the same trick instead of
writing cos theta and sine theta I don't
like these trig functions right I have
to rely on this thing okay so therefore
I'm gonna replace these guys with those
guys now pause for a minute a lot of you
will like why actually things are
getting bluff Assad bait like if you
compare this this line to this line like
that was better wasn't it like that was
quicker or simpler and you're like not
fine okay you like me and now you're
like nothing forgiven this is a terrible
game and he's what I would like it a 2-1
when you go to clean your desk right you
gotta clean this especially off linked
well 13 years of you know education
probably unless you're a very particular
kind of person it's a bit of breakfast
okay and you're like you might search or
something and you're looking like a cat
you know you have to get everything out
of the way and things look worse for a
long time before they get better
right like everything sorta ends up on
the floor doesn't it and you're like
okay what but now that's all there now I
can like categorize it knocking grouper
and I can see some order among the chaos
okay yeah I know it looks worse I know
this was but having everything that's a
precursor actually making this desk
makes sense okay you're with me
okay so take a deep breath just like I
substituted trig into here I'm gonna
substitute these Taylor series just by
the way I know it's like a long time but
just to help you like appreciate I just
think about the enormity of being able
to make polynomials fit for me that's
kind of crazy it's a special kind of
crazy okay so I'm gonna run this off
while I'm doing that if you I'll let you
get a head start this first line here I
just want you to write your obviously
don't need to write all the terms just
enough to get a puppy that's all I'm
after okay can you do that for me can
you write this but with these guys in
place go ahead